From a grizzly blood bath to flying French
body parts, "Prey" offers up some of the "Predator"
franchise's most gruesome kills.
Spoilers ahead.
While the famous alien hunter is known by
the name "Predator," it's merely a reference
to what it does for sport.
It hunts.
The species, however, only hunt other predators,
animals that can fight back.
Otherwise, there's no sport in the affair.
Being new to planet Earth in this film, the
Predator begins hunting wildlife.
It first kills a rattlesnake.
It even eventually kills a massive grizzly
bear.
But at one point, however, it targets a wolf.
Just like with its human prey, the Predator
stalks the wolf using thermal vision.
However, the wolf is only out to get lunch,
eying a tasty-looking rabbit.
After the wolf gives chase, it nabs the furry
snack right as the Predator strikes.
The two predators then spar, with the alien
hunter getting the better of the canine.
Later in the film, the alien hunter is seen
polishing the wolf's skull.
It's a clear callback to the Predators' tendency
to claim trophies.
One of the most harrowing moments in the film
comes when Naru encounters a grizzly bear.
The animal, in all of its ferocity, sets its
sights on Naru and aims to kill her.
Naru flees and spots a beaver dam in the middle
of the river.
She dives underneath the water's surface and
pulls herself up inside the fortified beaver
home.
Meanwhile, the Predator hones in on the massive
bear intent on collecting another trophy.
The Predator is strong enough to pull its
kill from out of the dam and hoist the massive
mammal over its head.
Naru stares in terror as the cloaked predator
lets the animal's blood pour over its body.
It's a powerful, iconic moment for the franchise.
Perhaps one of Naru's biggest detractors,
Wasape, leads the hunting party with all the
bravado he can muster.
He has zero faith that Naru can be an effective
hunter with his snide comments.
"Who invited you?
We won't be gone long enough to need a cook."
It was always clear from the get-go that Wasape's
ego was going to get him into trouble and
lead to his demise.
When the Comanche hunting party hears strange
sounds in the woods, they become wary.
A creature is making guttural clicking noises
high in the trees, but they're unsure what
sort of animal it could be.
After Wasape kills a possum thinking it was
causing the rustling in the woods, he goes
to retrieve it.
That's when three red dots appear on his chest.
He is swiftly killed with three darts shortly
after.
Like most of us have come to expect, there's
a moment when the Comanche hunters face a
mass slaughter at the hands of the predator.
The moment comes after the hunters embark
on a trip to track down Naru.
She's left camp to hunt and investigate this
strange new visitor on her own.
"If they don't see, I will show them."
While on the prowl for the lion earlier, Naru
insists to Taabe that they aren't alone in
the forest.
Her senses are keen as she notes the oddly
skinned snake from earlier.
After finding an injured fellow hunter who
was attacked by the mountain lion, Naru rightfully
wonders why the mountain lion didn't finish
him off.
She postulates to her brother that something
scared it away.
Furthermore, the native hunters suggest the
tracks left behind are from a bear, though
Naru correctly points out that the tracks
indicate an animal walking on its hind legs.
Unknown to the warriors, the Predator watches
and waits for the right moment to strike.
After killing Wasape, the rest of the hunters
jump in to attack.
Fighting this hulking beast one-on-one is
a bad call, however.
No matter how skilled these warriors are,
their abilities are no match for the physical
prowess of the Predator.
It begins systematically butchering them one
by one.
It's a bloody sequence that sets a precedent
for the massacre of the fur trappers still
to come.
Itsee is a member of Taabe's band of Comanche
hunters who initially endeavors to slay a
mountain lion.
In the battle sequence where the Predator
rears its ugly head and slaughters nearly
the entire hunting party, Itsee is nowhere
to be seen.
After Naru flees from the alien hunter she
finds herself in a field of tall grass.
Itsee grabs her and pulls her below the grass
and motions to her to be silent.
Itsee indicates that he can see the beast.
Steadying his bow, a trio of targeting lasers
appears on his forehead.
Naru, knowing exactly what that means, is
quick on the draw and causes the Predator
to miss his shot.
Naru only buys poor Itsee precious seconds,
however, as the Predator gives chase.
Still invisible, following them through the
tall grass, the Predator closes in.
The creature runs Itsee down in the field
and guts him in a grisly display.
After the Predator has eviscerated most of
the Comanche hunting party, the fur trappers
remain, alongside Naru and Taabe, of course.
The fur trappers attempt to use Naru and Taabe
as bait for the alien hunter by tying them
to a tree.
However, Naru knows from experience that the
Predator won't target her and her brother
while they're incapacitated.
Instead, it's going to hunt all the fur trappers
lying in wait.
Of course, what ensues is a massive slaughter
of the fur trappers.
The Predator actively uses all of its tools
and moves, dismembering the hunters left and
right.
At one point, it chokeholds a man to a tree
and then activates its gauntlet shield that
opens up and decapitates the man.
It even wields the weapons brought by the
fur traders, including an ax, and lobs off
another man's arm before finishing the job.
One unfortunate soul aims his pistol directly
at the Predator point blank.
The Predator stands still as if to beckoning
the man to fire.
When he finally pulls the trigger, the bullet
ricochets off the Predator's helmet and brings
a swift end to the trapper.
The Predator ends his massacre by leaving
behind a wrist gauntlet containing three explosive
drones that eliminate the rest of their party.
"Raphael Adolini" is the name inscribed on
the flintlock pistol the Predators gave to
Detective Mike Harrigan at the end of "Predator
2."
It was a cool nod to the idea that the crew
of alien hunters had been visiting Earth for
a few centuries.
That very flintlock pistol becomes a key tie-in
to the prequel film "Prey."
Credited only as "Raphael," he is one of the
trappers who initially finds and imprisons
Naru after she is snagged by their bear trap.
While imprisoned at their camp, Raphael is
the only one who speaks her language and can
translate for the other fur trappers.
The only thing they want to know is any details
she can share on the beast that is hunting
them.
Later in the film, all of the fur trappers
are slaughtered by the Predator.
One lone trapper makes it back alive: Raphael.
Though his leg is severed below the knee.
He asks for Naru's help in exchange for his
flintlock pistol.
Unfortunately, when the Predator arrives,
it finds the incapacitated Adolini is still
alive and finishes what it started.
Adolini may have been a random fur trapper,
but his flintlock pistol is a cool relic that
connects the great Predator universe.
Perhaps one of the most emotionally upsetting
deaths at the hands of the Predator is Taabe,
Naru's brother.
While he displays a measure of doubt about
his sister's hunting skills, it's more likely
that he is being protective of her.
However, he does ultimately relent and allows
her to join the hunt.
During their trek, Naru shares her anxieties
over another hunter in the woods given the
strangely skinned snake and the odd attack
patterns she is tracking from animals in the
wilderness.
Taabe dismisses Naru's instincts, however,
a move he won't soon forget.
Of the entire Comanche hunting party, Taabe
manages to outlast them all, standing strong
right beside his sister.
When Naru is attacked by the Predator in the
fur trappers' camp, Taabe jumps into the fray
with Naru, making one final request of her.
"This is it."
"No"
"Bring it home."
It's a loving message for her to finish the
job knowing he won't survive combat with the
beast.
The Predator does get the better of him and
impales Taabe through the back with its wrist-mounted
claws.
When the Predator targets Naru, Taabe, who
is seemingly dead, gets one final blow and
injures the alien hunter's leg, but meets
his end as a result.
This fuels her motivation to end the Predator
once and for all.
No matter how ferocious the Predator may be,
the odds are stacked against it when it comes
to surviving the film.
But it's not brute strength that gives humans
an advantage.
A fight with the Predator comes down to a
game of wits.
Every human victor always bests the alien
by outsmarting it at its own game.
Naru is a master at this.
Early in the film, she is temporarily trapped
in a bog but manages to pull herself to safety
using her ax and rope.
As the final confrontation approaches, Naru
uses her flintlock pistol to knock the Predator's
mask off, robbing it of its targeting system.
She takes the mask and positions it to aim
at the bog.
She intends to pull the Predator into the
mire where the creature will be forced to
shoot at her from a distance.
However, its weaponry is guided by the mask's
targeting system when active.
Once the Predator does fall for her trap and
makes the fatal mistake of pulling the trigger,
the bolt bends away from Naru and ricochets
off multiple trees before plunging right through
the Predator's skull.
In effect, she tricks the beast into killing
itself.
This time, the human victor takes a trophy
from the Predator, something that hasn't happened
in previous films.
As she walks back into her camp, it's clear
that Naru has become as vicious as the alien
beast that stalked her.